so in 2011 2012 you're part of the group
you leave in 2012 you're now i believe
27 years old
when you went into the group nine years
ago 26 27 years old nine years ago
you're
teen 16 17 years old 18 years old what
have you noticed that's
changed with antifa from then in 2011 to
today
well you know something antifa today is
far more dangerous than anything that i
was part of and i mean
there's this book but written by a
leftist activist
and it's called the the anti-fascist
handbook it was written in 2017 or
published in 2017
and on the back of the book there's this
gentleman named murray from baltimore
who
um he's a self-proclaimed antifa
activist
and it says the reason you fight them
with letters and and making phone calls
is so you don't have to fight them with
fists
the reason you fight them with fists is
so you don't have to fight them with
knives the reason you fight them with
knives is that you don't have to fight
them
with guns and with guns so you don't
have to fight them with tanks
now a lot of people see that this is
think that this is a form of
anticipatory self defense
that can be boiled down to the phrase of
like don't mess with me and i won't mess
with you
but that language is actually trying to
say you better sit down and shut up
or we are going to make you by any means
necessary
but with this quote we can actually kind
of break down uh antifa
activism if you will into different
stages the first stage is being
intimidation
and some destruction of property but
then it's quickly escalates
to force violence and then to deadly
force until you get the final stage
which is all-out warfare
when antifa in america at least in
america has been in different cycles of
this and
when i was in the in the 1990s we
definitely saw a lot of that
uh violence and the the late 2000s
and kind of when i was part of it we
were kind of in the first stage again
which is kind of intimidation kind of
yelling um
at people i remember i mean i broke in a
few windows as well as uh
try to intimidate a few people but i
gotta say this
um yesterday i was actually at um
in washington dc and i decided to uh put
on the black mask
and kind of infiltrate antifa and i saw
very
key differences between when i was part
of the movement
first of all they're open and by the way
when you're saying yesterday you mean
november 3rd election november third
election
yeah it's very important because when
they see this november 3rd is the day
that everybody's getting
going through the election so go ahead
you were saying in dc sure so
on election night uh i was actually in
dc and i decided to put on the black
mask and just kind of see what was going
on i mean i
i wasn't really sure what i was going to
find but i knew that for a fact that
antiqua was going to be organizing
first of all it is far bigger than
everything anything i remember seeing
the biggest things that i was a part of
was the occupy protest
and that came from people from all
southern california and
while those were incredibly big bigger
than yesterday not everybody was part of
antifa there was a lot of left-wing
activists as well as some
free market capitalists who were um
angry at the banks you know so it wasn't
just a left-wing movement although
it vastly was but at the very least it
wasn't all antifa
well yesterday it was like close to 200
people dressed in the black bloc
and it's kind of funny because they were
at first they were saying like oh like
no violence like you know don't trash
the city this is
we shouldn't have to do that um but it's
interesting because as soon as we
started marching within minutes
all of a sudden that went out the window
i mean they started threatening
journalists who were trying to take
pictures
and also i believe i wasn't present at
this but i i just heard a few
a few minutes ago that um there was this
gentleman who got
uh stabbed or at least slashed in in his
uh in his stomach
i mean they at first they were claiming
that it was going to be some sort of
peaceful march but of course
antifa is not about peaceful protest it
is about
shutting things down as using their
words
so you dress up as an antifa did they
talk to you and did they did anybody
recognize you or no one recognizes you
no thankfully not because i mean i
i mean i don't want to be recognized in
that rally but i make sure to keep my um
my mask at all times um i actually found
some pictures um
uh online for some of the news outlets
uh but anyways
you cannot recognize me but i did talk
to a few different people
i think the most notable thing to one of
the most notable things to
to point out though is that the media
i'm very disappointed in the media they
were basically taking marching orders
from antifa i remember back in my day
when i was part of the occupy stuff and
as well as
uh some of the anti-neo-nazi rallies
that i that i was a part of
um you know the media was there
obviously we didn't want to take
pictures of us
because you know that would reveal our
identities but we would just kind of
turn around
and just kind of avoid like the
photographers
well this time this antivirus was trying
to use umbrellas to block cameras and
not only
do that but actually push some of the
the reporters on top of that
the reason i'm disappointed in the media
is because i know for a fact if we had
done that
back in the day the media would have
just kind of walked away and then try to
take a picture
but this time a lot of the media was
actually listening to them as if they
were part of the movement as well
and unfortunately i think that speaks
volumes to a lot of journalists nowadays
what do you mean by that unpack them
when you're saying listening to them as
if they're part of the movement
what do you mean listening to them yeah
so for example there was this guy's like
don't take pictures
um uh you know like that can only
endanger us
and this journalist apologist like i'm
sorry like i didn't think of that
you know it's like well your point is to
just report the facts and just take
pictures of what's going on
not try to conceal the identities of
these people who are are a part of this
movement that are trying to
what organization was that person part
of that journalist
i don't know i just know that he had a
press thing here
um um i i didn't recognize any of the
outlets every time that i would see it i
would just see the the word press on top
i do know that there was this gentleman
um elijah schaefer
who is from blaze tv i didn't know that
at the time
but i later found out because i saw some
of the angles he was taking the pictures
of me
or whatever and he was one of the ones
who uh reporters who was
being threatened with uh you know he was
actually being a good reporter
he was being threatened and he would
kind of walk away and try to get a
different angle
but there was other reporters who just
were
taking marching orders from antifa yeah
i saw some of the videos both in dc and
la specifically last night with antifun
it wasn't looking good
uh in both areas it seems like um you
know
they're both uh you know creating more
momentum obviously depends on who gets
elected and a lot's on the line right
everybody's trying to find out what
happens next